this bavarian brewery's a gas thirsty
business and that's a big problem
germany is already on high alert after
russia reduced the amount of gas it's
sending
today it temporarily stopped flowing
through the country's largest pipeline
all together
sparking fears the supply line could be
permanently cut
the natural is
officially the nordstrom pipeline is
offline for just 10 days for routine
maintenance
it runs more than a thousand kilometers
under the baltic sea from vyborg in
russia to lubeman and germany
for the first five months of the year it
was operating at around 160 million
cubic meters per day on average but
since early june supplies dramatically
dropped so now germany's getting around
60 percent less
in war not all weapons are on the
battlefield and energy is a major source
of power for president putin if gas were
to be cut off to germany now it could
mean they don't have enough in storage
for the winter and that would put major
pressure on prices people and
politicians
and as europe's largest economy experts
say what happens here will send shock
waves across the continent
the moment the german economy takes a
hit it's going to be their economies as
well that will take a hit and we'll
essentially see
the effects across the european
economy not only in this country and
maybe actually even all the way down to
the uk because whether the uk likes it
or not it's still integrated with the
european economy
and a lack of gas means keeping coal in
play for longer
this
a big worry for this bio bakery keen
like many germans to protect its green
credentials
this
while the kremlin claims it's not in
putin's plans russia could cut gas at
any time
the pressure is now on the german
government to find the right recipe for
keeping the country's lights on without
breaking their climate promises
siobhan robbins sky news germany